hello friends daniel dwyer here mr thai
route hey good morning good morning my
friend how are you let's go to london
immediately let's start our work week by
going straight to london uh assassin's
creed syndicate is there this friday for
some reason um and we have a copy of it
here on playstation 4. i've been playing
a bit of it over the weekend you've been
playing as well i was yes
never got out of white chapel you never
did well i did a bunch of exploring and
we're gonna do a bunch of exploring
today uh this is about let's say 90
minutes into the game we've uh already
completed the tutorial levels which were
a little bit heavy-handed for me they
were they were they were boring they
went on a long time you know they're
kind of too bombastic i felt like lots
of like a train gets derailed and all
this stuff and you're like all right
just calm down video game i kind of see
what they were trying to do there like
let's make the tutorial interesting but
it just kind of went on way too long
there's loads of footage that stuff out
there already so what we decided to do
is we're going to get in here do a
couple of levels in whitechapel just
show off some of the missions uh and
then just sort of explore because yeah i
used to live in london you've just come
back from a trip in london yeah our our
area of where our former office is we
can go we can go visit southern right
you can go visit gamespot uk right now
so let's jump right in we're going to
have a basically look around at the
various parts of london uh and it's it's
kind it's like kind of surprisingly
accurate it's impressive they did a
really good job uh white chapel up here
is where you kind of start off you end
up you start the game in like croydon or
somewhere down south and then it sort of
it transports you up into the rest of
town uh so like saint paul's is here uh
liverpool street and all that's over
here like i think we've got london
bridge like southwark kind of is a like
it's all very compressed but like it's
pretty accurate uh
like waterloo stations here waterloo
bridge westminster big bends here white
hall you've got you know victoria park
green park buckingham palace uh charing
cross like it's all kind of
there and around so where do you want to
go first
uh
let's let's just start in white shop
well let's just go to southwark
adventure at some point yeah yeah let's
let's go for the walk so i'm playing
evie frye
who is one of the two uh protagonists in
this game her and her brother
jacob so you can actually swap between
the two of them which i didn't realize
you could do uh before we before uh we
got the game um you can just hit right
hit right trigger and it like straight
up like
like gta 5 style all right they're
actually in the same place last time i
did it it kind of transported me a
little bit um but i'm going to get
skills you should use your skills man i
have not updated my skills yet no you
got to use your skill points you have
seven skill points oh my god let's do it
yeah you can show off some of the skills
then at that stage yeah
it's great so all these ones at the top
are
the ones you start with they're all your
basic thing like whistle and knock
people the [ __ ] out so the best one by
the way that i love
you gotta use the automatic pickpocket
one oh yeah yeah that's just assassinate
somebody yeah yeah you take down or
whatever it's it saves you so much time
stops you having to hold the circle
button for about 15 hours and then
double assassination is great i went for
eagle vision two at one stage because it
gave me you can look through walls
straight away some of these are pretty
powerful actually right off the right at
the gate yeah um and they're different
for each like these are jacob skills if
you wanted to apply them to eevee you
could do it differently yeah and they do
kind of play differently we only get
this one like she he's a lot more of a
like a bruiser and she's a lot more like
stealthy it's the hollywood trope of
like the brother is like the reckless
you know crazy one yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna kick people's arms i'm just gonna
[ __ ] everyone up yeah what are you doing
i can't actually beat people up no which
is a bit long and then evie's like the
one that has common sense who's like a
cat the brother is like this kind of
child murdering crazy person you know
shoot children all right i'm out of here
i'm out of here uh there are hay bales
or rather
leaf bales which is pretty makes more
sense yeah i don't know london gets
pretty leafy yeah um and i will say
it's kind of impressive how big this
world is and how like look there's saint
paul's in the background like it's it's
kind of cool i've gotten to big uh i
guess high points in this game and
really enjoyed looking around so should
we just like should we go down to
southwark and then maybe like make our
own big bend to big ben yes of course
yeah that's it all right so we're evie
here let's for the sake of all our
uh london friends we'll go past saint
paul's and then maybe cross i'm guessing
this is the thing
this kind of looks like london bridge
but i i don't know if it is because it's
a train
it's not terrible is that before it got
shipped off to arizona oh yeah they sold
the wrong one it was the
one that was the other one way around
yeah tower bridge is the other one it's
yeah they sold london bridge i think to
lake havasu yeah and it ended up like
they yeah they got they had the buyers
remorse yeah um streets are real wide as
well yeah they made them a lot bigger
for the carriages
and i was impressed by the uh like the
carriages even like they drive on the
left side of the road and it's just like
everything it was even confusing for me
i was like oh [ __ ] oops i forgot him in
london and we can you can just straight
up jack one like gta style get out of
the way horse don't make me shoot you
like i shot that child pull that guy off
uh let's go this guy's facing the right
way and the one thing is so we're in
white shop at the moment everyone it's
like the whole city is run by goddamn
templars they're not really templars i
guess they're like a gang and you're
setting up your own gang to try and take
over that guy yeah the plot starts with
with evian or bro they're just basically
like we need to free london of templar
control and we'll do that through gang
violence i mean yeah i know we need to
free london of templar control and in
like put it in assassin control yes like
a perfect gang
uh movie mentality the lines are so
blurred at this point you have no idea
who's right and who's wrong or just like
you just go with it and you're meeting a
bunch of people like there's like
charles charles dickens charles darwin
yeah yeah yeah florence nightingale
really yes really it's i'm okay this is
great it's like who's who
alexander graham bell oh really yeah
isn't this man your agbs in here agb the
one thing i found though they've made
the cat the streets way wider but i
still end up like tearing these horses
into
like i like when you knock over street
lamps yeah all the time yeah like to the
point where i one stage i was driving
around thinking i bet one stage the
development team thought let's just take
out all the street lamps because you
just keep crashing into that all the
time constantly uh so we're at st paul's
if you do you know do you know anything
about the same problem no nothing so
saint paul's contagious
it's like the sort of the the the royal
cathedral like angling a little bit
protestant cathedral in london okay but
there's a there's basically this law
where there are a bunch of
it it's like a protected skyline so you
have to be able to see saint paul's from
a bunch of places where you are yeah so
there's a reason why
a couple of the like say the expansion
of the the the bank by liverpool street
is like
like while it's off to that side you
know they build like some skyscrapers in
southwark for instance so saint paul's
is like basically a massive viewing spot
in london i noticed a lot of places in
europe have like these weird rules where
you can't build tall buildings around
old buildings yeah yeah because you
wouldn't be able to see them yeah
although we'll see if the view up here
is actually pretty good this is certain
like was it like eight eight eighteen
sixty eight okay because yeah because
there's a couple of little monuments
that i was like oh that's not in the
game for some reason and then i looked
them up and they had actually been built
afterwards um so like climbing these is
like not difficult like i'm basically
just holding up like it's what i liked
in some of the early assassins games was
the like difficulty in climbing
something they just fly now they have
loaded up now it's like whatever i'm
just like who cares and instead of
eagles i think they're like pigeons or
seagulls or something which is pretty
good there's nothing even up there look
at that [ __ ]
yeah there's no for some reason some of
the things don't have secret
synchronization points like
that's the weird part by the way i like
i don't think big bang has later or
rather the clock tower you even see big
ben yeah it's over there so you both
might think okay yeah like
there's charon cross station you tell us
the industrial revolution because we're
polluting the earth right now yes and
because look at how busy that that looks
unsafe
there are too many boats in the towns i
think that's london the toms the farms
the wash the thames i like to say toms
um i don't know can you see a pile of
leaves anywhere i can jump no you can't
even jump wait go oh look down there
look down there that's it i can see it
i've actually gone too high
so i can use circle to do my stealth
get the [ __ ] down button you know like i
like oh yeah you see it right now
stealth descend i like the uh
yeah it's cool
there's there's the eagle
all right let's do our little
synchronization point i take it back
there is one
synchronized standard ubisoft trademark
you're gonna find into a tall building
and synchronize and find everything
and she's like wow rent here is
expensive i'm going back to croydon
and there's lots of these dollar signs
on him which i wonder if you're able to
like shops
yeah you could just go to hamley's just
and spend this
yeah i think you can like buy stuff and
then like i think you're going to be
buying up um
real estate yeah for your food dude
let's do a little jump just jump
there's something well that's close
that's real close evie
should be dead that's not even realistic
we're not even [ __ ]
we're not even the way down no dude like
i've still got loads left to do but it
is
a free run down
i love this part of it now the free run
down thing is my favorite thing they've
added i mean since unity i think it's
great it's super handy oh there was one
i'm an idiot there's one right there
that's fine i better jump into it just
for prosperity yeah
these are fun these are fun i would jump
on leaves as a kid yeah all the time i
still do now yeah which is weird because
then the kids are doing it too and
they're like who the hell are you older
mommy mommy yeah get away from the man
there's this guy like a tradition in
ireland don't worry about it
soap abbott's best cocoa powder so yeah
there's a lot there's a big element of
like british imperialism and like the
the empire like one of the main uh
people you meet in the game is a british
indian like second generation uh who
helps you a lot and there's lots of like
you know
the the
you know the sort of like i guess the
expansion of the british empire the idea
of london being so prominent at this
stage in history is like the reason why
this game is here you know like if you
what is that there's a line early in the
game if you control london you control
the world yeah it's like whoever
controls the spice controls dune um
let's let's get our asses down here i
don't even know what train station that
is actually
um
let's
let's cross the river what's your star
rating
oh this actually i do know where this is
this is oh god that guy's not very happy
and that's the thing like i mean it's
just get it away get out of the way
stupid londoners do whatever you want in
this game it does not matter like no one
comes after you like you even see like
those red bars above the gangsters who
are after you currently because you're
making a ruckus but like they don't care
yeah and i'm like i'm not really sure
how good like after playing metal gear
solid this game is a real
yeah like itself yeah stealth wise it's
kind of like it's so low
like i'm just crashing into people but
like if people see you you just beat the
crap out until they're dead that was the
one although this is early so maybe it's
maybe it's just a little bit not
challenging at the moment i will give
them a lot of credit here in terms of
like being the [ __ ] out of each other
because they're i i don't know what
studio uh what ubisoft studio made this
but
is it quebec okay i think so they did a
good job of like remembering that oh
yeah this is 18th century or this is a
industrial revolution london nobody has
swords anymore hanging off to their side
everyone has concealed handguns and they
beat the shell of each other yeah it's
like a brawler it's mostly fist fights
yeah and then every once in a while
somebody pulls out a shiv or something
and like and the cool thing about evie
and i think eb especially has like the
cane
yeah so she hides it and then she beats
the [ __ ] out of people we should get
into a fight because like i feel like at
least right now it's so
like it's super button mashy in a way
that like is is kind of well because
it's all like fist it's all fist
fighting practically but like it's
fistfighting in batman as well but at
least there's some degree of like look
at let's go in here what is this london
world news it's god free and [ __ ]
limited see i'm telling you does that
remind you of london yes of course
oh
london's finest tease let's go in
i have been in the building yet
i will say one thing the hdr in this
game is rad look at look how bright it
is outside it's very
oh getting some fire shark infinite boom
this kid's like oh what'd you look why'd
you knock down the log post lady
that's it my london accent is great
you're better than me way better than me
hello sir get a drink get a pint i'll
have one of your finest ales or i'll
stab you in the face with this knife oh
yeah
oh desynchronizing desynchronizing gotta
get out of here
all right i like how you threw a knife
in his face i really well it's london
mate yeah you know we don't i mean this
is don't have guns but it's it's just
it's not just big ben it's close you
want to climb up big ben let's climb up
well yeah yeah look look at that look
how many boats are in that river
if you've been in london and like never
it's not that bad it's like not bad at
all like there's no boats none i
remember once there was like a whale i
wonder if that's historically accurate i
wonder if there are that many boats back
though i bet it was i bet that's why
london was like such a
like popular
like our big trade tanks it had this
like
big massive river that like yeah opened
up like because london's really in like
it's quite in
uh what would you say like look at these
okay look at these look at these guys
what are they doing
the people in front of you yeah yeah
zombie [ __ ] like hey guys let's go he's
a bad guy okay so now you can you can oh
no get in your fist fight i'll get an
assist fight yeah yeah yeah yeah show
them the fist the the fist the cuffs
combat here okay so some i just want to
like i kind of want to make a point
about it somebody i think it's maybe
jarring coming from mel gosala but some
of the ai and like the combat mechanics
in this game is a little bit funky like
what is going on here so they like if
you right click you clearly see they are
they are bad guys there's your eagle
vision
he's in the number three
i don't know what that means exactly
does that mean like you have to be
number like they recommend level three
to oh maybe maybe i don't know yeah
let's try that like the fact that their
buddies just died and they're like oh
whatever yeah hey what's up and then
they look see then they recognize you're
like wait who are you oh my god that's
right you can beat the crap out of women
in this game
well you're a lady as well yeah i know
look you got the cane
did you what did you do to her bam bam
bam so if you i'm basically just mashing
square here i was stopped guys oh okay
okay
and there's there's a couple of
different types of like if he blocks
himself i can
you'll see the counter indicator like
it'll turn yellow like that you can
counter but you don't even have to you
just mash like you said well if yeah the
counter thing or if you
uh
if they block themselves you're able to
you have to hit this button to um
basically break through the defense but
like the weird thing is you fault in him
now no
the weird thing is that they telegraph
it so like it literally comes above
their head that person is just like yeah
whatever yeah cool um it literally like
it comes up x over them yeah so it's
kind of like oh it does body and a lot
of it feels like it's almost automatic
which is a little bit whatever but
oh no i want to throw them
in the river sorry
like so many shopping carriages i will
throw this gentleman into a river oh i
couldn't get over there it's my fault
that's my fault you can get her she's
he'd be strong these people are like oh
stupid traffic look could you get off
the ground
you nam cheese there you go
oh no no no maybe the big guys
try it
clearly you have to move the body so the
carriages can get by you know i really
should have got that automatically
you should have well only when you
assassinate people you actually get to
loot them you really cannot throw people
over the ledge there that is super sad
sorry it's my fault
it's my fault i mean maybe the brother
can because he's like stronger actually
no they're the same they're the same
height they are actually the same height
he is a bit stronger though so but i
like the fact that she has this cane and
she's she's a lot more nimble and and
generally
as characters i way prefer her because
the brother's kind of an idiot well he's
like that stereotypical
like again we were talking about this
like it's like the brother and sister
and the brothers the reckless kind of
crazy just i'm going to [ __ ] everything
up yeah and then she's the one that has
common sense yeah he's just like no we
don't have to go that way yeah we don't
have to be we don't have to be crazy a
bumbling idiot uh so here we are at um
at westminster
and big ben is above us let's go climb
big ben let's do it we can't climb big
ben because big you know what big ben is
ty
this is like
the the first piece of london trivia
every different person's ever what is uh
what is the real big benefit big ban is
the bell the bell it's not the clock not
the clock tower no big bad but we can
get up and see big ben okay then clearly
i don't know what i'm talking about so i
think it's just called i've been calling
it in my entire life everyone does okay
so that's like this weird piece of like
that's the most boring piece of
information you touch trivia you tell
every tourist who comes to london did
you know big ben isn't actually the club
tower it's the bell tie
look this i'm not climbing on the face
of big ben right now that's pretty good
i wish i could i should we should wait
around until it's like
the hour yeah why is she moving i'm not
even what's happening are you is she
just she was just doing that all on her
own okay that was weird
the game has become sentient
like there's big ben yeah oh [ __ ] jesus
evie calm down calm down evie calm down
just get walk down just
great by the way that is one thing that
annoyed me is that
when you want to get inside of a place
when you're climbing up something it's
very difficult sometimes yeah it's a
little better it's an awkward yeah i was
going to throw a nice thing then got it
and see if i could but i don't actually
have any knives left sorry
they finished off big then so you can't
ring the bell i i used all my knives
stabbing that shopkeeper yeah in the
face
all right let's get to the top come on
let's see the view
i'm not sure if this is the highest
point and it has to be
i feel like saint paul's might have been
talking about guitar maybe
you can get there oh there's a flag
that's music there's a little secret
thing oh can i synchronize
i think i can i think i might have
already synchronized up here actually oh
do you get to do it again where's the
look at it so here we are this is uh
that's one of the tallest points
westminster there
we've got that's waterloo station over
there
the busy river
i wonder if
the stacks are down there um
yeah try and cross there you can see
nelson's column in the distance see
right above easy's head
yeah that's yeah that's uh trafalgar
square nelson's column we'll climb that
in a second i guess there's uh vicki
park there's buckingham palace so 10
downing street is basically like there
where her head is so funny that was the
name of the pub where i used to live
attend dining street really yeah that's
what we americans do really good at just
taking names out of london and just
saying that's a pub
and it kind of stops up near green park
so there's green park up here so like
where regent street starts it kind of
like that's where it ends but it goes
down the whole way into
uh lambeth as well down here
so
i i don't i don't know if you're like me
where you kind of have assassin's creed
fatigue right now but oh yeah um yeah
have you seen the points
yeah what's that show
i love this series like assassin's creed
one and two and and brothers are some of
my favorite games no one notices yeah
like whatever i liked uh four of this um
there was aspects of three i enjoyed i
wanted to like three so much because
well this is the one out one thing i
wanted to ask you even though i know
you're irish but it's like when the game
takes place in london yeah like does
that
make it appeal to you it does you know
like it doesn't like i i lived there for
four years yeah i've been here for
almost two like there's an aspect of
like nostalgia like i was playing this
last night and walking so we're like
walking down whitehall right now and
you've been there yeah like i know this
street really well yeah so like that was
kind of i have enjoyed that so i guess
that was the sort of aspect of 3d you
probably would have enjoyed yeah i think
outside of that like outside of some
really like
i don't know i think they've done a good
job of constructing a what looks like
like a like a real city like a real
london but it like outside of the
the architecture i'm not sure how
londony this is i imagine it's going to
turn into some doctor who [ __ ] where
it's like it's like it's like this you
know internationalized version of london
like it's cool i'm in horse car it's
parade like it's cool that this is like
in the game well i mean the one thing
about the one advantage they had now
especially with this time period is this
is after the invention of photography so
they have photos of all this stuff like
they can go back and look at all this
and be like okay this is what
westminster looked like back then this
is what this area of london looked like
back then we can kind of recreate it a
little bit better so they've always done
a really good job i think of recreating
these cities yeah and
sorry i just got a little bit distracted
because i think these people are
actually playing qriket and you are
bothering them i am well those security
guards over there are like
don't hurt us
i'm going to try and walk away but i
want to see this cricket game oh they're
they're oh they're all scared damaged
yeah it's weird i don't under the gang
stuff in this game is interesting
like the so there's an arch that's
usually here
malicious arch or something i always
forget and i was like oh where's the
arch it's not here in this video game
but apparently the arch actually wasn't
built until
1905 or something so look queen's arms
see i'm telling you right now that's
just a pub let's go in and stab the
landlord
oh can i have a drink mate you know but
you know we know all of this swig of
this if you don't mind i got a skill
point beer bottles ooh i collect beer
balls you see that
oh and you have six skill points
available it just unlocked um it said
you've collected one of four beer
bottles in westminster what happens when
you give birth i like that well it's
kind of it's probably like a find all
the pubs in england in london yeah so
it's like a pub crawl yeah in the video
game like i'm totally okay with that
um okay let's lose some more skills then
i guess let's see eevee skills you
happen to look at that um i think
they're all the same i think you can
just tailor
jacob
to be specific so you have like two
different play styles essentially like
you can have her be like super stealthy
and then you can give jacob all the
combat skills or you can just do vice
versa man i got a lot of skill points
they give you a lot of skill points at
the gate yeah and that's i think yes you
know you're level two sweet yeah uh
we're not allowed show i think we
haven't got many restrictions on this
stream uh one of the ones is we can't
show any of the real world stuff
the like abstergoey stuff no which i am
totally okay with because i you
i hate that stuff so much well they i
mean they just lost it at that point i
mean i don't even think they care
anymore like i i'm sure like there's
that i think of somebody who never
completed unity i'm missing out on the
entire start of it
because it all seems like they're
they're starting from a point that i
don't know where it is so i'm like
totally disengaged with it so i'm
totally fine with that i will say one
thing though at least it's like it's
kind of hands off like it's pretty quick
it's basically like a cutscene or two
and then you're back in the game well i
mean they it's the way this starts off
can we even talk about it i don't know
maybe not
whatever
it's so short and quick yeah like it
happens to go and except i think this
time you are now with the actual
assassins you're not with
the templars you're not like an employee
who's researching a video game
um don't say any more which is black
flag i guess right that was black flag i
think so yeah
the story is so convoluted at this point
it actually makes metal green make sense
so you were so you were in london pretty
recently do you know what i'm climbing
right now um
i've seen that i don't know what it's
called this is nelson's column so we're
he killed a bunch of people in the name
of england so they love him okay they
love that stuff is he a good guy or a
bad guy i don't know he killed
people i don't know like
england have this weird thing where they
like they also like celebrate lots of
people who killed a bunch of irish
people so oh yeah they're like they love
oliver cromwell oliver cromwell was a
bloodthirsty we're like that in america
too we worship
psychopaths and sometimes some aspects
of our lives so like it's kind of pretty
you know there's like all this stuff to
see there's
like leicester square i think is in the
back we should be behind there
but i don't know if it was just if it
looked like leicester square like that
before isn't it it's strange to think
that like so you have charles dickens
you have charles darwin
you have florence nightingale and you
have alexander graham bell
this game if you think about it they
have relatives that are still alive
today like they're part of the bloodline
yeah they could actually go and go back
in time and see their great great
grandparents it's like
first lebron james's family could do it
and that's weird now all these folks can
do it yeah
that's pretty crazy like i'm a
descendant of alexander graham bell
there's my great great grandfather i i
love the idea of somebody playing this
game like some kid in america playing
this game and then
years later
going to london and like seeing like the
national gallery like that's it right
there like saying you go there you've
got like same martin's in the fields
this anglican church is literally right
there yeah in london like it's he did a
good job recreating a lot yeah this sort
of stuff i feel like mostly the touristy
areas like i don't think white chapel
looks like white chapel at all like
parts of sonic don't really look like it
either no that looks so different now so
like there's the national portrait
gallery to our left as well like there's
loads this is the way the street bends
is identical like i have been drunk on
this corner right here looking like
queueing up for an atm here like more
times than i can
i can tell you right here where all
these people are hanging out this guy
here i'm like going up just he's just
like hey what's up right now there's a
barclays machine where that guy is was
this before uber or after yeah did you
order an uber horse carriage it's before
the tube as well because the tube
station's right here well so the tube is
being built as this was all taking place
but i don't know if we can go down there
um yeah i wonder if there's like later
missions or something the underground
was around eight well i think 1868 is
the time frame here so i'm almost
positive that they were building the
underground at this point that doesn't
already exist and if you are from london
and you've watched where i've just
walked
uh
yes this is actually
leicester square so leicester square
used to be a going to the uk tour guide
somewhere i know right that's exactly
what we're doing right here so this is
actually square it used to be a a garden
like this and then it wasn't and then
recently they've rebuilt it like this so
when i just got back from london i
stayed there and there's the cinema okay
the big odion i think it's an odion
that's right there oh so you stayed here
i stayed at leicester square really yeah
wow like that's where i was near that
was my stop on the tube on the tube yeah
so that was it just back there yeah uh
and then it kind of stops being a little
bit london in the past year like when
you walk up towards piccadilly it sort
of tailors off and it stops before
regent street one of my favorite things
is if you go up to where chinatown is
remember chinatown in russia square
uh no it's like just to the
it's up here i know because there's a
bunch of really good irish buyers up
here to show all that i think in
chinatown
they can think of right now so this is
where chinatown is it's uh scare the
buddies but it's like owned by all the
dudes now it's like
one of their
one of their like
gang
just get him ah i can't kill him
i can't just stop running people i can
throw a knife at his face i know which
is weird you can step you can throw
knives at shopkeepers
shopkins oh shopkeepers
very nice get in there get out
get the [ __ ] out of here love it it's
great and they don't have they don't
have mobile phones back then or 999. no
they can't do anything they can't do a
phone no goddamn thing uh
i like member it's all true it's all
real live you have to drive on the left
side of the road oh now i know where we
are this is really i keep walking i keep
wandering into little places yeah i
drive side roads yeah
this is what's happening i've been
americanized in america way too long man
um union flags all over the place uh
yeah all right let's make our way back
up to whitechapel then shall we and do
some missions that's fine any any
questions from the chat uh
from the chat
uh looks beautiful
why is he running is it f 30 fps
what is the park here's here's a real
question is the parkour more responsive
than unity
um
it's been a while since i've played
unity that's why you only for like five
hours and it feels very similar yeah i
think it's very similar the one thing
that made the one control thing that i
felt was coming out of metal gear solid
and a bunch of us talked about this
morning in the office is that it does
feel
like obviously it's not fair to compare
two games together maybe like that but
just as somebody who's been playing a
lot of mds it does feel a lot more
floaty like control wise it just feels
less enjoyable that way so probably more
like unity but then this is a different
game there you know you're moving your
character around towards different ends
but i did find that a little bit jarring
let's start um 30 frames a second what's
the running i think it's running at 30.
yeah i mean i obviously don't know for
certain but
as i've been playing metal gear on my pc
for the last 75 hours like that does not
run like that and it looks pretty it's i
really like the understated color
palette they did a good job it kind of
reminds me like london where it's like
like you look at the puddles on the
ground they're reflecting the buildings
like they're they're doing yeah and then
there's the hdr again like they're doing
a good job i'm curious about the windows
because that's always what i look for in
detail oh really if the windows actually
reflect the other buildings on the side
of the street because that's what i
think it does
does it reflect you though it's a
question and the answer is
no
that might be the same building there
yeah so it doesn't see you but it does
see the other it's wonderful it's
probably harder to see you in terms of
like programming that but look at it
uh all right so let me see here we've
got these formations to take over white
chapel we could pick any one of them so
there's one were you um
i saw that one good the other one was
that one right there oh spit it feels
market i'd love to go there this is just
you just beat the gang leader here all
right it's actually it's cool it's good
maybe we should do that to catch an
urchin i don't know what that one is
that's that's right i've done all three
of those and i forgot what they were
that's the kid oh the kids okay yeah so
you have to recruit the kids to help you
out
and harold's right and then you you hunt
some uh
all right let's go to spitfire's market
first of all um i've been up here a
bunch this is a nice uh sort of it's
about as open air market as you'll get
in london it's it's under
hey it's like open air but not
it has a roof go on so
all right let's use a new jump in front
of the train you can jump on trains i
know that
you jump in front of me i'm sure you can
see there's the uh good i told you how
to get there i like that yeah it's got
gps time this is very like the crew
except it's just on the grounds floating
above you
my gps my garmin is telling me to go
this way
this is very white chapel these very
tight streets yeah although they're way
tighter than this
some of the other ones um this is jack
the ripper territory i used to live not
too far from part of town
all right excuse me excuse me excuse me
what's that thing
big smoke stack
all righty let's go do a mission since
we just spent the first 30 minutes of
this arsing about
which is fun
no it's cool show it off i just you're a
great tour guide i learned a lot about
big ben and everything else man you know
we don't work on tips but if you want to
leave something in my hat when you're
leaving it's fine you know
i'll buy some beers tonight on you
that'd be great evie is way more fun to
play though i will tell you this much
yeah so far
i like i just think the other guy's a
jerk
well it's just
he's over the top in every way
okay here we go let's let's break this
down so we gotta
we gotta eliminate all blighters
yep and free and protect the captured
clinkers so the blighters are the enemy
gang that's in this game and the uh this
isn't the kid one but you have to
you have to
protect protect the there's like a bunch
yeah that's not what the clinkers are
yeah they're like a group of people they
actually i think they end up helping you
after this when detecting the shooters
look at to run to the main shelter and
call you for enforcement you can
actually recruit people to help you do
stuff
so that's the look out there the guy
with the little eye icon on him
and see you have that new perkness you
can see behind walls and everything else
like that which is great so
yeah very very useful so we should kill
this guy first especially when he's on
his own like this so and so when now
when you assassinated him you should
yeah see wait did you do the uh
yeah so you automatically looted him oh
great when he said those people
automatically lose this kid saw but
hopefully he'll shut his mouth you're
fine and we'll just put this box
don't worry about it hey kate you saw
nothing all right taking the dump look
at all these kids
where are the parents in this oh that's
right it was all child labor back yeah i
know yeah
the good old days you know what i'm
saying yeah
so i guess i've got nine more of these
guys to kill i kind of want to kill them
stealthily if possible i know man it's
it's my fault for not oh i've got one
life back okay that's all you long all
you young millennials should
like play this game and think back to
old 1868 london and how
youth worked back then yeah rosie didn't
complain as much
everyone has entitled and also you could
just get stabbed by
just
she's got throwing knife and you got
five pounds there you go pans oh it's
great to have pens again yeah i was
saying that you can't leave those chests
there's lots of money like how much cash
you got now she's got four and a half
grand four and a half grand back then
that's a lot that's a lot to count that
for inflation that's like 75 million
dollars right now
can i have another one in here it's
going to have this massive yeah why not
just put them all in there love birds
all right let's uh let's open this thing
boom what do you got
you got some chemicals oh yeah there's
crafting in this game too oh yeah like i
don't know if that was in unity i forgot
i didn't get that far it's a big
component of three i know that
i'm sure it was the crafting stuff has
always been let's see if there's any
other questions for this guy i don't
know a horrible job
stab
boom
i'm gonna
how many people do you recognize i i
throw them all in there why not
because you know metal gear is really
good about that right like you can't
throw like three guys in the dumpster it
won't let you do that
no i think i think that's bad i think
video games should let you do as many
people as possible yeah
there you go put them all in here look
at them all just hanging out imagine the
poor kid that has to take a [ __ ] who
walks
so many dead bodies no what happened i
got seven more of these jerks left
who else we gonna get
all right
it says eliminate all bite is three out
of ten but i don't see i i don't have
that many on my map so i gotta be oh oh
no there's somebody looking at the
toilet where this one just kill him oh
no he's not going to know buildings
okay oh sugar you're fine
all right so let's see i'm going to try
and do my my little whistle
i think it's
how do i whistle again i don't know
maybe i can't whistle in certain spots
let's see if i can kill him you can kill
me though
yeah
eat it whoa wait what what happened what
did you just fly through the water is he
on the ground
is that a cat down there all right i
think that's a chip chicken okay where
did he get
he's gone
he she separated
evie's such a good assassin that she
just
pulled him into a different dimension
all right just don't worry folks it's
still an assassin's creed it's fine um
one less to put in our murder toilet i
guess
i really was looking forward to you
putting him in there
it's okay it's fine it's so weird put
that guy in there i'm assuming this is
like the level you should be to kill
this guy but even though it doesn't
matter should i just in front of all
these people do it that's what i did
last time last night did the exact same
thing you're doing right now they're
punishing he's gonna kill this person
he's shaming them oh that's i'm gonna
shame him
shame on you and then you get all his
money and no one cares right they're
just like look at you and then they run
one away like okay
they're like cheers love
oh no no no there's a couple of them
that's fine see that's where they think
you are and that's where i am
and then you can
to death
boom boom boom
it's i don't know oh he was gonna help
he was
gonna be on your yes the guys in green
usually the ones you're gonna recruit
rice and then you can um they can help
you out and so these fellas haven't even
been you haven't even realized if you
get your did you get your double
assassination point then i have okay so
i'm gonna try and double assassinate
these people but also one of the things
i like is sort of one of the takeovers
from three is that the trees are also
sort of part of the you can still
parkour them yeah
perhaps we can harness the game now
you're in a tree now you're like connor
let's see if i can do a double double
assassination here i'm not sure you have
i think you can
oh my bad i know everyone maybe can we
do it on the ground
if i walked up behind them i probably
could have done that but
i can throw a knife here as well if i
want
she's really weird
i got one more of these jerks to kill
where where is where is he there he's up
there
let's get him from see if i have any
questions i'm sorry yep 30 fps on
consoles that is true
same ac glitches just that one where
evie made him vanish
bam
dead dead gone there's a lot of ladies
i'm killing yeah well they were part of
the gangs lady killer all right we did
it it's our first little mission
all right should we rate this
let's rate this activity right now i've
been doing that i get i'll be honest a
lot of the intro ones i gave a one i did
too all the tutorials i gave one stars i
feel like this was the toilet for me was
a good one
but then there was a bug happened so i'm
floating with three like a three maybe
or three out of five
maybe
yeah it was a bit too i would give it a
three all right
this is the problem when they're like
there's not a lot of
challenge in this game or
any kind of consequence if you get
caught or seen yeah so far i wonder if
this is like an early game and so yeah
you unlocked it i will be honest as
somebody who like like infamous seconds
on man unlocking areas of cities is like
my weak spot like i love that [ __ ] you
like that oh so yeah all right let's go
catch some urchins
how about that that's the kid one
what's happening
you get that too by the way at some
point yeah that's the
see now like they're they're on your
so they're on your gang now
great
so this is the combat i'm mashing square
x because it pops over his head he's
like you could have countered her but
whatever yeah yeah so the ex popped over
his head because that's me trying to
break through his defense but like the
fact that it even tells you it's kind of
like yeah it's a little bit
it means that you're like
concentration levels in these fights
pretty low yeah like i don't know maybe
that's like a personal thing but like
one of my biggest gripes with how
assassin's creed has evolved is that you
are killing thousands of people in these
games it's like every video game now at
this point yeah did you remember
assassin's creed one and like even two
so one yeah was like it made you not do
that because if you got into a giant
fight with a lot of people they [ __ ]
you up and the first assassin's creed
and also like you were spending hours
trying to get information to kill a
single person yeah so
and then it's kind of the same in two
where like at least the people who were
fighting were kind of i don't know they
were army people in an invading force in
like in like a holy war so in that way
you felt like it you know there was a
certain amount of like morality
justified whereas this is just gang
warfare these people are just like
yeah people
so it seems a little bit the interesting
thing about this game is okay so the
first assassin's creed i don't even know
i forgot because there's
there's so many assassin's creed games
but i remember the one of the ones i
played i believe you're assassinating
real people in history at least the
first two uh some of them are right yeah
not all of them are real but some of
them are real you pro oh look there's
your bro oh maybe i'm playing as my bro
yeah
um
but i believe
you can't really do that in this game or
even like some of the newer ones because
if they start assassinating real people
some of these people like i said still
have relatives that are alive that's a
good point
i mean we've killed
not that you would kill
you know alexander graham bell or
charles davis like we killed castro in
video games or attempted to i guess but
he's kind of an [ __ ] dude there's a
game called jfk reloaded yeah
oh it's clara od
yeah so this is like the little brat you
have to help and like free her friends
does she have an irish accent
mr green said we might be able to help
one i mean her name is clara od exchange
for our services we ask a small face
nope well
so everyone has these kind of posh
accents as well which is weird
apparently these two there are several
factories fries are from croydon and i
don't think they'd be speaking that
largely but then who knows like i didn't
grow up in 1860s england yeah but they
all have the sort of british accent you
get a lot in a lot of dramas that go in
downton abbey and the way larger people
speak in return i hope there's some real
gruff like she sounds kind of eastenders
i'm like for an appointment what are
these terms
we accept
she's i like when they just
yeah i thought you and me are just gonna
start you know yeah that's we made deals
man i got swine flu in london once
before i don't but that's yeah
and this is why the plague broke out
before this yeah people spitting yeah
all right i gotta reach the warehouse so
now you get to save all our little
friends i'm gonna do some hot parkouring
see this happens sometimes when i'm
climbing up and i gotta release x
yeah this is the stuff i don't like
though and then climb up [ __ ]
and then i go to the side for like no
reason and then getting down is a pain
in the butt sometimes like you have to
assassinate some guy to actually jump
off that i wanted to kill him because he
saw me wow that clothesline whoa that is
a stiff clothesline right there she's
the way he's washed
like you can just climb on it somebody
put too much starch on those clothes
yowza all right that's boom yeah for
some reason when you're climbing up
sometimes it just it just stops climbing
yeah you just gotta like go left and
right i don't know it's happened quite a
lot you get stuck
yeah
what was there was that dlc there was a
dlc i think for
i want to say three where like they
basically just gave you the ability to
fly
in washington
like it was like the george washington
dlc maybe i don't even know but it was
like owl was like owl mode or bird mode
maybe the chat knows what i'm talking
about
and it like basically gave you the
ability to basically just fly into the
world essentially right
and i forgot what it was called
i gotta release some kids apparently
look i can look through all this [ __ ] i
love click clicking in on the right
stick is basically just shadow of mordor
yes to like see somebody
yeah stealth kill the leader although
maybe you could do it in assassin's
creed before order i can't remember all
right so here's some kids i got a free
i love this i'm freeing these kids
presumably so they can then work for me
yes correct
well they're going to do something for
you i think they're going to [ __ ]
make shoes that's what they're going to
do for me
yeah eagle mode me that's what it's
called
i'm going to kill that jerk all right
all right there must be a way in here
except for the front door
oh yeah right there
hey guys they don't even care about you
they don't give a [ __ ] nope
but everyone is just really easy to kill
now hold left triggering this knife him
from there
oh we have a gun
okay oh that wasn't as stealthy as i
wanted yeah whatever
i'll use i'll use the again see no one
does [ __ ] like they don't hear anything
they just keep moving
jesus what if i throw this body down
maybe that will
like in metal gear if you pick up a guy
and throw him he makes so much noise
that all the other guards like what the
[ __ ] was that
this guy even noticed i just threw a
body down there
you can air assassinate him
so the weird thing i was thinking about
i was talking to my step brothers over
the weekend and i was hello
they're younger
let's go
are you okay
i was talking to my step-brothers and
i'm like yeah are you excited for this
game because they have never played an
assassin's creed game wow how old are
they uh 19 and 21 okay all right so they
haven't played any of the older
assassin's creed they maybe played unity
i'm not quite sure i guess the first one
came in 107 or so yeah so a while back
that was with patrice what's his name
yeah who's now doing like what that
humankind odyssey game or something yeah
there is a long story of his uh troubled
problems with ubisoft yeah i'm actually
really curious to see where he takes
that game is still in development right
yeah
it was and it's very reminiscent of like
the precursors of like all these like
world events yeah and jade raymond of
course who was also instrumental in
those games is now working on a project
for yeah at the moment yeah
you're free children go anyway speaking
of children you're your stepbrothers my
step brothers yeah so i'm talking to
them and i i i wanted to see like
obviously i've hit fatigue with this
franchise in this series but i want to
know like other people haven't like
maybe if like you're new to this series
this is going to interest you a lot i
don't know i i asked my stepbrothers i'm
like does this it all interests you and
most of them said that
they might check it out but they're not
super fascinated by they all want to
play halo counter attack
yeah of course haley this is out on
friday i'm halo out on tuesday tuesday
yeah so two big games coming out this
month yeah i'm interested in that i
wonder if the people in the chat can
because i know there's a lot of people
like our age that have been in this
industry for a long time
just shut up we're tired of this game
yeah but it was just he was too big i
had to shoot him look oh look at his
busted ass arm that's amazing look at
that because it means this guy's arm oh
jesus like again the chat is filled with
people like this who are just like i
just came here to see how bad this game
is
so i'm curious if anyone is actually
like
new to this franchise and actually wants
to play it and maybe has never played an
ac game before like at this stage it's
just like what do you do with an
animalized franchise to make it
interesting
i don't know i feel like they put so
much time and effort into story and
but do they really do the story anymore
now after they killed off desmond it's
like oh spoilers oh no not that's not
that stuff i'm just like the story in
this game they put a lot of time and
effort into like assets like i don't
know like craig creating a lot of it
just seems like so high production but
like this game obviously involves
thousands and thousands of people put a
lot of work into it yeah but it just
seems like it's always in the sort of
wrong areas i don't know um let's let's
free some more kids and see and then
you'll win next month that is one more
group right there so we've only been
playing this game for like
we've only had it for a living not even
an hour so
uh like i'm wondering to see how i guess
how much variety is in this and how much
that matters because meliga solid is a
game not to keep like banging the mega
solid drum but it's a game where like
you basically do the same like couple of
missions over and over over and over
again but it works because when you get
caught like when interesting things
happen when you get caught whereas in
this when you get caught um it basically
defaults to a sort of a and usually a
game has one like either the gameplay
captivates you or the story captivates
you right like in in great circumstances
both captivate you but like and metal
gear it's all about the gameplay the
story is [ __ ] it's dumb as [ __ ] but
like in this game
the gameplay and the story are kind of
like weird you know like i just don't
know nothing's really grabbing me i love
the world i think the world is
yeah is really impressive i think that's
why we started off you know great this
activity yeah like
three two
i'm going to be generous and do anything
um
yeah
like i think that's why we started off
looking around london because to me
that's the most interesting part yeah um
but you know this is very early as well
like obviously we'll have a review up
which will be
the the the full experience um alexa
korea will be reviewing this game for
you guys squeeze uh all right which one
harold drake or good uh
aberdeen dude it's on the way just do it
any requests from the chat actually we
can we got the whole of london here as
well we can go fap about if you want
nothing stopping us those dudes got a
penny farthing a lot of people just
talking crap about this game
it is interesting though like i don't
know assassin's creed i would say was
never a game i think that was
you remembered it for the gameplay i
think it was always the story that
captivated why i don't know i think did
you like that i mean no i mean well i
like i like patrice's stuff and like uh
in obviously santa time and prince of
persia and stuff that was amazing but
like it was just basically taking that
gameplay and kind of i think that's i
don't know i is that like unfair yeah i
think assassin's creed two and
brotherhood two are like the best
design games in the past generation i
love those games like they completely
like prince of persia the games were
were linear third-person action games
true assassin's creed was a like was on
the cusp of the first like open world
video games like before that those
didn't really exist
or at least taking that sort of linear
progression storyline and placing it in
an open world um but the story i just
remember being really i like i was very
captivated by the story ezio's one was
was fine like it was a little bit messy
it was a trilogy yeah no uh sorry um
i'll tell you as man i was a little bit
messy but yeah yeah ezio's trilogy was i
think well up until revelations was just
maybe a bit too much yeah that's when
they started getting into this weird
annualized franchise territory did you
ever see that the short film they
released like it was like an animated
film where they conclude ezio's story
yeah
no he meets the um the lead character in
the um
uh assassin's creed china chronicles or
whatever
chronicles china yeah really wow june
maybe is her name
should they meet it's interesting what's
up bro
it's a cool animated short you can go on
youtube and watch it it's good yeah i'll
look for questions here
i have a question what's the rating part
for uh that basically goes back to you
myself
like they they have metrics perhaps and
watch people enjoy
each level yeah that's cool that's
interesting
oh look that's an ugly woman hello
you're talking about
what's this
you're not a woman you're not a woman at
all dude
he needed to see the top of his head the
mustache he had no idea yeah he's like
the fried twins green mentioned
facial animation and stuff is super spot
on i was expecting you to be discreet
henry green said that you could help us
go unnoticed i like it
what are they talking about i don't know
this is how it will work fry twins
though they know what's up i will give
you the names of criminal guns okay
we're gonna go assassinate people got it
assassin's creed bring them back to me
quietly do a quiet squeeze and i'm gonna
be evie very hairy strange old lady that
looks a lot like a policeman
that's pretty good yeah
that is the weird thing about this is
like again you can pick whoever you want
to play with but then when you start
certain missions it's always either oh
is it really like well i don't i in the
first couple hours it's either jacob or
evie that you're starting with well
that's the tutorial stuff i wonder if
like in these open worlds maybe if
that's more
because apparently they each have their
own kind of
oh oh oh i brought straight in by
accident
oh i ran straight in by accident you're
fine that's on wait what happened yeah
okay oh kidnapping i did this yet last
night went unexpected this is funny
because when you press circle to kidnap
them uh move
okay to move them around so you you walk
up really slowly behind the guy
yeah you kill these people after i after
i dis
this a [ __ ] pier
you you can fight all of them oh god you
shot me jerk holes fight them all
show them the
counters there's a counter yep
hit circle when circle appears over
their head yeah i mean it's like as bad
as you got boom
i can't tell what they call them boobies
bobby
bobby bobby
you're gonna hate me with his trenching
oh yeah that guy just straight up
yeah he's a cop killer now square hit
and square hit square look for any more
questions here
these guys just [ __ ] they need to
change their tampon
dude why do you say those comments sorry
it's just one of those things you just
see it and you're like read it out loud
you gotta read them all and then pick
out the ones you want to talk about you
can tell i don't do this very often
all right look at this guy this guy
hasn't noticed the dead body he just
walked over
he just walked over this guy's dead body
oh i just pulled out a gun he also
didn't notice that okay this guy
deserves to be kidnapped because he's
clearly an idiot oh i can recruit you
yeah he's oh i'm sorry he's your buddy
you're my bro got it
do i have to restart this mission is
that what's happening did you find the
guy
i killed a bunch of people and i imagine
he ran away he's yellow he'll be like
highlighted in yellow
something unless you killed him
which is possible
i mean i definitely [ __ ] up that
mission like that's yeah goes without
you get up to a vantage point and then
you can highlight him and
yeah i think you he's just somewhere in
this world well no i think the mission
it's not over yet because i'm still in
it oh you are
but yeah but i don't know
i think you're done because it doesn't
give you any mission objective yeah but
look there's no mission to pick
otherwise oh yeah so i don't know maybe
we'll vote wrong or about right
or one hold i can tell that guy to go
places
yeah i think maybe i need to restart
this mission
how do i even do that
and in there
resume congratulations
oh
this is confusing
hello
person i'm supposed to kidnap i think
you killed the man
is it that guy
wait is he
is he yellow
i don't think so okay
oh well
yeah
i don't know i don't think so
i think we're stuck in this level
forever ty
set marker i'll see if i can answer any
more questions here i'll vet them this
time
filter out the garbage
can i buy this meat
this guy is my friend you're my friend
oh i wish you could start that mission
every night yeah i'm trying you can't do
that you have to be able to do that
trying to figure that [ __ ] i'm going to
take it out on this guy let's go shoot
him in the back of the head
oh kidnapped okay there you go oh you
just killed him didn't he oh sorry to
kidnap anyone got it okay my bad i need
to just kidnap a person is that good
yeah that guy's dead
so i got a sorry it's my okay i figured
it out i thought it was a specific
person you had to kidnap and maybe you
can't just kind of anybody i know that
again you walk up really slowly you hit
like r1 and then you like you um you
hold your knife against their back great
and you can guide them to a carriage and
put them in there
okay so you can knock them out here we
go can i kidnap you
there you go all right
what's happening over there this looks
interesting
so what i gotta do is gotta walk around
i think you are also in stealth at this
point too
like you're not gonna attract any guards
restrained
do you say i can put him in a carriage
well
in the mission i played you put him into
a carriage and then that and then you
drove that carriage somewhere
i have no idea so i still think you
failed that mission or it just stopped
but whatever you can just walk around
with this
this handsome bloke and this dude
walking behind me what's going on well
he you recruited him he's gonna follow
you yeah but he could at least stay like
more than five yards behind me
he has your back stop being weird bro
nothing's going on all right we i see
the okay i'm gonna i'm gonna just kill
this guy because whatever yeah
okay that's brutal i see i see there's a
red circle back where i was so maybe i
can go back there and do it again yeah i
can see the guys back yeah a lot of
people are asking this is better than
unity or runs better and i would say yes
the stuff i played and i was playing on
xbox one um last night it seems like
it's a bit more modest in terms of
graphics as well it feels like like it's
it's not bad look you know it's not
that's a good looking game yeah but it
feels like it's maybe there you go okay
kidnap that dude
yeah
that's cool it just resets oh my gelatin
okay
dalton's assumption so you can go in go
back bushes go in the bushes
are the leaves now that's hey okay
okay now you just creep up behind him
slowly
oh he found you
all right we got it
i like how he's just sitting there shoot
that guy
yeah he's just sitting there just
chilling there it's really weird so
hey i'm not gonna run away i'm just
gonna sit here and watch you beat the
show this guy
oh my buddy's helping that's good yeah
it's really weird a bunch of the like
most
most of the um dogs all look like the
same dude like this bald dude whereas
this guy just looks like that dude but
with hair
you know what i mean like all the ladies
all the ladies
yeah exactly yeah
all right
become anonymous to complete the
objectives by shooting people probably i
think if you hop in the trees you can
garden bushes
or just kill somebody okay now you can
get them i keep oh god
wait now you have to kill a cop
killing cops is like video game 101 [ __ ]
he [ __ ] you up i was trying to shoot
him all right all right let's we
probably need to restart this anyway
because i arched it up so okay so
a little tidbit last night i played with
the new xbox one elite controller okay
that thing is amazing
is it 150 goddamn dollars no but it's
the best control i've ever played with
in my life
and it wanted me for 100 so good it's it
feels like
i wish that was what the xbox one
controller really was and not 150 it
makes no sense but
you want to be elite that's great
uh we're playing on playstation there's
no multiplayer in this one at all guys
yeah they took it out they didn't use it
we got that question
uh
kill all the bobbies
i'm tr i'm trying to not kill all the
vibes right now my problem is i keep
killing all of that you fought the law
and the law won
that is true where is he going what's
even what's even attacking at this stage
oh my god your buddy's getting he's
getting gang update you might want to
help him oh wait there's the guy you
have to get yeah i'm trying to like wait
no is that him
all right here we go
i think it's a side mission where you
tackle him and get like no this is the
mission i just need to catch up with him
that's all
all right here we go here we go is it oh
it is the same dude you're right okay
okay so hopefully i can do it without
getting attention
you missed evie you idiot you'll never
be a rugby player
there you go good you got it
you show us the customization menu we
can do that okay here we go here we go
okay so now you have to guide
him to a carriage i think it's the other
way yeah but there's too many guards
over that way so i'm gonna bring them
this way i think you're stop squeezing
when you're with somebody like that
oh yeah there it is you can see your
goals oh that's the carriage okay i
think that's the carriage all right that
might be where you have to take him
with me because i thought it feels like
it's a long way tapping x to restrain
him when the game says tap x to restrain
get off me can i go faster i can okay
and again
the mission i had there was a carriage
i don't know where that is
off me for but whatever
i'm gonna make this guy run a bit a lot
faster there's another police officer
so i'll be quiet around the police
officer terrible mistake you've made
and then the chance to scream save me
bucket when i'm past the blaze
she's i mean that guy is a lot bigger
than her yeah she's she's using like
cough mcgraw or something yeah whatever
you call that stuff what's going on
she's channeling her inner
chuck norris and how's this guy
okay these people are my friends out of
my way kids kids get away kids get out
of okay let's get out of the [ __ ] away
kids they're just not budging no
kids and i don't want to hurt you you
got them industrial arrogance don't [ __ ]
about all right where is it over here
240 meters look at this little scamper
this guy's doing
does this game or even the series now
have any purpose
server purpose in this industry good
questions todd you can do it good
questions
i thought that was good actually i was
talking about the story does it serve a
purpose i mean a financial purpose yeah
probably 100
like yeah like i'm sure some fans
probably this game still sells millions
to people somewhere
uh but yeah like the annualization of
this means that they
can't really reinvent the wheel every
single time they do it which is a big
shame because i think that's what people
like us and fans who are watching this
on on streams
is what they they want because we're
like big enthusiast gamers whereas i
think this game appeals to a more
mainstream crowd which maybe doesn't 100
percent it's not you should just recruit
this guy while you got this guy captured
yeah right there you go now he's your
boy
um i might if you're almost you're
almost there man like this is not a fun
mission again you did it
and then you drive him to this location
all right so that's my fault i don't
think you're supposed to be doing it
this way walking home
like it's fun i'm getting like a power
trip out of it because they're asking
about the anime stuff i haven't seen it
if it's in this game yet so yeah there's
some like real world stuff but that's
under embargoes we can't show it but
um it hasn't been i haven't been walking
or it's only been cut scenes uh have not
been walking around
a world in first person out of the last
game
this is cool this is easier because it's
like this is my part of town
wait where's the where's the thing going
where's the carriage going there i wait
it's that marker right yeah take them
too that green marker right there see
that little on the far left there 66
meters away take them there
no anyway in the in the original part
you put them in a carrot you drive them
there and then i forgot what happens but
yeah so you're not acting like an idiot
like i am oh no oh did they notice
you're fine
just you're so close to this point just
walk them over there yeah there you go
let's make sure there's no one else no
we're good all right so it's a carriage
just like that yay you got in there
you got a bounty you got some money
thank you
you're welcome fredrik rate this
activity
thank you for your feedback
oh all right let's let's not do another
mission how about we just faff about
somewhere should we what was it jump in
front of a train somebody said uh try
and get onto that you can get on top of
trains i don't know if you can jump on i
don't yeah i haven't done it yet so
maybe where's the train in here is that
right there never flow straight stuff is
over here okay is there one of the
closer
are we near this one oh yeah right near
this one we're right beside this one oh
it's right there all right let's do it
let's leave a marker
let's go
go evie go right above us right there
nice
hey drunk guys
i thought the there were some cool train
moments in the beginning there
all right there you go
now get on top of that like overhead
i could be waiting right i don't know
see how long it waits let's run towards
the train station
whenever there will find good questions
to answer here no worries whenever there
was somebody who whenever the like tube
like ran over someone
which happened a lot on my line the
central line oh here we go here we go uh
the the announcer would say uh
the train is late the train is late due
to persons stuck on their train they
actually would say that yeah oh nice way
to go man
that was impressive don't fall off you
sure
i like that
parkour down
i think she's scared
so where's this train gonna go let's
just find out just take it for a ride
all right let's go through let's let's
just explore london i train
right on top of that smoke i bet it's
really hot on top of that thing it
wouldn't let me get there
how can we go in you can go inside the
train yeah you can go in there hey
passengers that's pretty cool
everybody everyone what if i just do
this
like where they gonna go
good point
what
what
next gen [ __ ]
just can you shoot are you loading up
look at this job that kid is through the
seat right there
oh yeah sit down yeah what happened
he just disappears now interesting
if you kill one more civilian you will
descend jesus christ okay assassin's
creed
he's putting coal in there
i'm gonna put coal inside of his brain
oh come on
desynchronized assassins did not kill
civilian standing of course that's horse
[ __ ] right there they were
very fair people all right any more
requests the thing spot um let me just
read this real quick i noticed the
counter buttons again have they made any
combat improvements at all we were
talking about this earlier but because
now because at this point in history
nobody walked around with like swords
hanging off their belts
uh everything is now fist fighting
with hidden weapons now so the combat
has i guess simplified yeah it still
feels super mushy though at least at
this stage like who knows maybe when we
unlock more stuff but right at the gate
it doesn't seem that compelling they
want to see the customization stuff
again all right you're going to shut it
real quick if you want to yeah you have
more skill points so you can spin that
stuff um let me see let me see about
kittens
there are a lot of trolls now in the
chat room don't even say that i don't
need to
uh all right inventory what we got
here's some stuff
upgrade my gauntlets upgrade my gun
upgrade my cape
gives me more stealth colors i could
change my colors buy some colors look at
all these colors
one thousand dollars for this [ __ ] or
pounds so a thousand pounds now would be
what like like
1700 yeah yeah yeah and that's like back
in 18 whatever so that's probably 1868
so yeah that's i probably switched
500 000
jacket you got there way to go scales
so you got one skill point
you can use slayer
listen to slayer while you fight
that would be awesome if that was true
near that state if you hit them 10 times
i'll do that especially with her because
she like hits people so fast
um
let's see what's in the e-store
buy helix credits
additional in-game currency you can
expense all that if you want go for it
get in-game currency i'll approve it get
crafting resources you can just buy
everything now right
wait they really wait so can you hit
buy that all right let's see what
happens buy this
hit x helix i have zero helix
okay not enough helix credits would you
like to buy some yes you can use my
credit card go yes yeah uh tay wait in
the back all right
oh it's gonna take you to the store oh
it's not there yet okay
all right it's not for sale clearly
there's micro transactions in this game
so we don't know how much they are
unlock maps what oh you can unlock
crafting plans wait so can you really
just buy yourself to like be an badass
in this game like it can not buy any
helix credits it doesn't say so we don't
know what we don't know what the
what the so that hasn't been unlocked
yet they haven't explained what this is
all about ubisoft club freaked me out
because i was like all right you guys
already have uplay and you have a game
called the crew and now it's ubisoft
club and it kind of freaked me out a
little bit wait what's this i don't know
maybe we shouldn't show this maybe we're
not that showed up i don't know i don't
know this just in case you feel like
yeah
all right what should we do one more
thing before we we wrap this thing up i
love my favorite part of this game is
browsing around
london
like just it's [ __ ] about
stealing carriages
yeah all three of you just ruined that
guy's perfectly great coat it was a girl
plant posts why not
good move by the way
i always like to ride carriages on the
sidewalk too it's great this reminds me
of remember die hard trilogy on the
playstation one yeah that's
you go first person and it's just like
blood wiping on the windshield
look at this [ __ ]
ram oh it rambling yeah you can ramp
people yeah you can just hit square like
rhyme into people and your carriage even
takes a little bit of damage yeah did
you see it it like side swipes like the
horse makes
keep going and there's no consequences
or you know there are people chasing you
i think but whatever screw it who cares
boom
go evie knock over this lady oh mister
look at the devastation
left behind you are a monster any
oh look requests can you run a carriage
into a train i don't think you can get
on the train oh oh there's a border
there's internet video games is
happening right there um
i don't think we can get the train the
characters on the tracks yeah because
they're all elevated
uh
no there's not 60 fps we have
established that
um i mean we've got a buckingham palace
so we're gonna go to buckingham palace
yeah i'll try murder the queen maybe
we'll do that
i mean right now ireland is still under
a foreign rule so i'm all about
assassinating the queen right now
the 18th trial
yeah yeah i mean we're cool now but back
then english people were doing some not
cool [ __ ] too no my folks so
uh we're this is green park here best
named park in the world
so i think it is are we in vicki park or
we
yeah unconquered westminster so that's
yeah so buckingham palace is here okay
let's go see the queen going down gotta
save the queen i've actually been
through this park i think
you guys playing qriket here they are
the pink cricket easy girl let's watch
them playing qriket don't worry what is
it with what is with the english in
cricket
it's a sport it's like saying what's
with the americans in baseball i know
but like i'm i'm not
talking [ __ ] about cricket i'm just
curious about cricket and like the
history of it uh do you know anything
about it um like it's an english sport
and then they export it to the rest of
the world and the rest of the world
beats them at it i know it's really big
in india yeah it's big in india big in
australia
big in like south africa
um i mean clearly somewhat it was before
baseball right okay cricket was before
baseball yeah i imagine there's some
sort of like lineage there where yeah it
has to be i mean yeah you hit the stumps
you hit the hit the ball that's what i'm
saying what are the rules like okay that
little that that wicket thing or
whatever there's two of them see there's
one up there so he hits that he hits so
he's the guy the guy who's pitched the
pitcher or bowler can't believe we're
doing this and he's trying to hit the
stumps okay to get that guy out so it's
it's like getting three strikes so if he
hits it guy's actually got it no but no
and if the batter is that what they call
him
yeah the whatever let's say batter yeah
if he hits it
he's gonna try and run between the two
wickets and every time he runs
but it's also like home run thing where
if he hits it and then i do in the
background catches it without a bouncing
he's also he's out yeah okay somebody
else
one and you're gone one but how many
outs into the other oh like ten you've
got ten ten batters go out oh he's hit
it oh he's out he hit the wickets he hit
the wickets he hit the wickets nice did
he he did yeah i said they've come off
so you're out [ __ ] sorry
all right let's go see the queen
let's go
so that's the rule of base that's the
final rule so you get murdered if you
see you thought you were going to tune
into the stream and and you found that
you got a lot of good information about
not just london but about cricket yeah
and now we're in [ __ ] buckingham
palace man and apparently back in the
1800s if you lost in crooked you got
eyes shot yeah so you got iced
someone's shooting so much someone might
be aiming at you right now yeah
hopefully i can get to the top of the
pile that's fine okay cool
uh let's see here
all right we're here
nobody's noticed i wonder if there's a
synchronization point up here
my favorite part of playing these games
is the synchronization points yeah just
like finding them and like climbing
things i don't know there's a yeah yes
good job
check me out i'm on i'm the queen of
england i'm the queen of england
so that's buckingham palace spoilers so
the queen's there yeah we're on top of
them can we go find her it's a big man
over there yeah we can try
don't try and find it i doubt you can
find and kill who is the queen at this
time i don't know
queen someone tell me in the chat margo
blau blah blah blah
it was before the germany was before the
germans took over
you know like the current clearly before
the germans
do you know you know the current like
queens are what are they called again
they're called the
they renamed themselves in the 1910s the
queens the current royal family is of
german lineage oh i didn't know that
yeah so i had no idea they renamed
themselves in the 1920s and 10s because
they were like because they were all
yeah so what are they called now the
house of whatever it is whatever it is
that's like a that's not really sure so
victoria was the queen during this time
oh really okay since the victorian era i
get it
okay all right let's jump down we killed
some of these uh wait so
the queen of it the the what colin firth
in king's speech he was queen george or
king george yeah that was like was that
like that's like after this i know like
was it the same line though right i
wonder absolutely right yeah let's shoot
this guy
jesus christ how many times have to
shoot these guys
getting [ __ ] up oh my god he [ __ ]
you up okay wow all right shall we shall
we leave it there i think we should
probably all right
that's uh
that's assassin's creed syndicate right
there at this friday on playstation
4 and xbox one
yes pc versus coming out november 14th i
believe um we'll have a review up on
gamespot.com later this week november
19th 19th 19th okay so yeah once all
once fallout 4 is already out we have
we'll have a graphics comparison today
okay cool so you can see which one you
want to buy that's where you can fight
between the two console versions which
ones you like better yeah
two consoles and uh yeah review will be
off uh soon enough i'm sure
if you just joined we sorry if you just
join tuned in and we'll have uh this
will all be up on our uh youtube channel
on gamespot of course um so you can
watch the entire play through uh you
might have missed certain parts like we
climbed to the top of big ben yes we did
we explored uh westminster i tried to
shoot that child you did you got into a
train shot or you actually made a child
sit by shooting by shooting him you you
oh you uh you
stocked the bathroom full of dead bodies
yeah i i stabbed the landlord in the
face you did or the shopkeeper yeah yeah
in the face uh you explained to me the
rules of cricket yeah that was great
yeah and then we did and we uh we drove
we did on the carriage we crashed
everywhere and yeah so you can watch all
that yeah and more on gamespot.com
thanks so much eric tay coming in super
early setting this up uh thank you ty we
got a meeting thank you danny absolutely
to see what's going on in the rest of
week on game spot so we're out of here
thanks for watching now playing and
we'll see you guys next time
you